welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel whether you'll float if you
can't wait for the release of it chapter
two and also don't have the time to read
the massive epic that is Stephen King's
novel then this is the video for you
throughout this I'll be going through
the entire ending of it and giving my
thoughts on how this may translate to
the upcoming film I'll be using clips
from both the original TV mini-series
and the new films just to kind of
iterate the points so some characters
may look slightly different at certain
points in the video there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined about it
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now I've just finished the book
myself and it's definitely worth
checking out if you enjoy the films with
that out the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for click in this video
now let's get into my breakdown of it
okay so unlike the first film the book
isn't told in chronological order with
the perspective constantly jumping back
and forth between the characters
childhood and adulthood at its core
though the ending of it centers around
the reformation of the losers Club Mike
has silently stayed in Derry whilst the
rest of the losers Club have gone on to
lead pretty successful lives in their
respective professions but after the
death of Adrian Mellon at the dairy
carnival
Jiri contacts the group to carry out
their oath bill has gone on to become a
successful horror author and he lives
with his wife Audra who plays into the
story later on Beverly is a fashion
designer who is married to an abusive
husband named Tom Eddie runs a limo
company Richie is a successful comedian
Ben is an architect and Stan is an
accountant all of them reluctantly
answer the call except for Stan who soon
after hanging up slit his wrists in the
bathtub it's safe to say that the film
is carrying this across as in the
promotional material Stan is missing at
the restaurant at this restaurant they
reunite and they begin to slowly be
tormented by Pennywise who throughout
the book manifests in different forms to
try and dissuade them from going to his
lair he even frees Henry Bowers from the
mental hospital that he's been stuck in
since a kid
after a confrontation with Mike the
character is killed Mike is hospitalized
and at one point has to fight off a
nurse that's been possessed by Pennywise
it's really scary stuff and pretty much
put me off ever go into the ER even if
my arms been bitten off Pennywise also
reaches out to Beverly's husband Tom and
orders him to capture Bill's wife which
he does and he takes her to Penny wises
lair where Tom dies from seeing its true
form and order goes into a catatonic
state now whilst all of this is going on
the losers Club are slowly remembering
their childhood and gaining strength
there's an awesome chapter where Mike
brings Bill his old bike silver back and
this reminds the character of happier
times with their newfound unity the
group - Mike descend into the sewers and
it's at this point that they come
face-to-face with Pennywise who has
taken on the form of a giant spider here
they perform what's known as a ritual of
Jude which is a very higher dimensional
esoteric moment that sees Bill and
Ritchie and to Penny wisest minded to
try and fight him if you remember from
the first film the belief that they can
beat penny wise almost transforms the
weapons that they use and Eddie who
believes that his inhaler has acid in it
sprays it in the creatures face which
hurts it pretty badly
Pennywise isn't out of the fight yet
though and he kills Eddie those who
didn't end up any wise his mind discover
that Pennywise is actually female and
has laid eggs and Ben destroys them
whilst bill and Ritchie inside Pennywise
his body find its heart and destroy it
bill finally kills Pennywise and he and
Ritchie managed to escape which is when
the group leave the lair with Audra and
Eddie's body now I don't think that this
part will happen in the film as there
are rumors that there could be a third
iteration excuse the pun but at this
point all of the scores that Pennywise
inflicted on them his kids disappear
which indicate that the creature is
finally dead at this point
Jerry begins to flood and the downtown
area of the city collapses which for
those who read the book will understand
that Pennywise is dairy and dairy is
Pennywise so without the creature the
town cannot exist Mike moves on and
begins a new life Ben and Beverly become
an item and Ritchie returns to
California bill stays in dairy with his
wife and together they ride on silver
which wakes her up out of a
atonic state and she finally comes back
to life free from Pennywise because of
the love of Bill this ends the book and
I can see the film adapting the majority
of this due to its lengthy runtime the
ritual of Jude is going to be in the
film and this will no doubt be one of
the most thrilling scenes in the movies
that think we'll take a trek through the
history of Bari and even showcase when
Pennywise first came to the town now the
rumoured follow-up film will apparently
focus on the children of the losers Club
returning to the area to discover that
Pennywise has not been to feared the
movie will also apparently show
Pennywise his origin story and follow
his journey through laning and dari and
allowing a settlement to be formed there
so that you always had a steady supply
of food for when he slipped out of
hibernation if it chapter 2 is indeed
the biggest horror movie of all time as
it's predicted to be then I can
definitely see them heading down this
route potentially not killing Pennywise
at the end of the film all letting one
of its eggs survive either way I'm
really excited for the movie and I can't
wait to see what it delivers in
September if you haven't read the book
but this video is piqued your interest
and I definitely recommend that you pick
it up it's hard to do the work justice
but it's the epitome of great
storytelling and has so many amazing
moments in it that it's difficult to
really ding it for anything other than
its length and of course love to hear
your thoughts on the book if you've read
it and if not then let me know what you
hope to see from this video in the final
cut if you enjoyed this then please give
it a thumbs up as it massively helps me
out and make sure you check out my video
on every time that penny wise was hidden
in the background of a scene would you
be linked at the end if you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then you can follow me
on twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully i see
over there after this also just want to
let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of John wick 3 and blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
ending of it in the comment section
below the one will be chosen at random
on September the 10th and the bureau
will be shipped out from them to a
bigoted surprise it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit
Ribe thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you